- No one expects a five-star
meal on a mountain.
That's just crazy.
(rock and roll music)
- So we went on a backpacking trip
up in the mountains, the cold mountains.
- I almost got hypothermia
and now I'm super sick.
- We have a lot of extra freeze-dried food
so we're just gonna do
a little taste test.
- In case you didn't get enough
of rehydrated food last time.
- Is it all, is it all meat?
Well, I'm vegetarian.
I don't think I'm gonna do this.
- [Chantel] See ya, Jen.
(triumphant music)
- [Woman in Overalls] Shepherd's
potato stew with beef.
- Just from looking at
it, I can't tell you
exactly where the beef is.
- It kind looks like (bleep).
- I don't want it.
- Whoa.
- It tastes like every food from
Thanksgiving dinner mixed into one.
- That is very salty.
- Right here, right now not stoked on it.
But if you were hiking,
it'd probably be fine.
- This reminds me of the
lunch ladies in movies
who just scoop up a big slop of (bleep)
and just throw it on your plate.
- [Woman in Black] Louisiana
red beans and rice.
- I can already smell it.
It smells very, very flavorful actually.
- You can't tell that
this was prepared in a bag
just based on appearances.
Little bit salty, little bit peppery.
- It seems like it's
rehydrated well actually.
So the texture is fine.
- It's pretty basic.
This is straight up just rice and beans.
- This is pretty filling
though I'd probably say.
- Imagine if you're
starving on a mountain,
this is probably great.
- You cannot tell it was
cooked in a bag though
so props to them.
- [Woman in Overalls] Thai-style
coconut curry with beef.
- I will say that I'm the
most excited about this one
'cause it looks the most fun.
- I see little flat noodles
which look interesting.
I see broccoli and I
see bits of beef again.
- Smells like biryani.
It smells basically like rice and spices.
- It's very chewy.
- I think this is the best one.
- This is definitely
the tastiness in terms
of complexity of flavors.
- In the other dishes,
all the flavors kinda
ran together, but in this
one you can taste like
the individual beef and the
broccoli and the peppers
which is pretty nice.
- It's not a, you know,
Michelin star, but it's
definitely fun.
- No one expects a five-star
meal on a mountain.
- I could definitely see these meals being
good nourishment after a long day's hike.
- It's dehydrated food in a bag that you
put boiling water into
and everything tastes
better on the mountain.
- I'd probably eat these again.
If I'm in the middle of
nowhere and I've just
had a long hike, I want
to eat as many carbs
and as much beef and potato as I can.
I would eat camp foods
that tasted terrible if it
meant they wouldn't attract bears
because (bleep) bears.